speaking before a supportive Union crowd
blocks from the White House Tuesday
President Biden made the case for
another four years we're in the cusp of
major change we're creating jobs again
manufacturing has come alive again early
campaign teams already emerging abortion
rights lgbtq rights and access to the
voting booth Vermont Senator and
one-time Democratic presidential rival
Bernie Sanders was quick to endorse the
Biden ticket yesterday saying the quote
last thing the country needs is a Donald
Trump or some other right-wing demagogue
to undermine American democracy with
such a calamitous and failed presidency
it is almost inconceivable that Biden
would even think of running for
re-election nearly half of all Democrats
say they don't think Mr Biden should run
again most of them citing his age he
would be 86 at the end of a second term